and i'd like to see it now so this is
zion warming up we don't have them it
could be another two three weeks but
chuck you you had a visceral reaction to
this it looked like me and shaq had a
baby
[Laughter]
he eat good in new orleans worried about
chico oh man
no and you know i'm i'm i'm joking and
i'm serious what do you look like
she's like oh [ __ ] we had a baby over
the summer
hey you know what adam yeah first of all
i'm concerned okay
i am really concerned
about
you know when and i tell this story i'm
i'm i'm being critical it is what it is
moses maloney moses malone said to me he
said i was fat and lazy
and i started to cry a little bit
and really yeah i did want to i mean
because i couldn't kick his ass yeah he
was moses alone but it was a turning
point in my career
and
he's already hurt you should not get
hurt when you're young
and
he's already had surgeries on his legs
now he's got a broken foot
he's gonna have to learn
even when you're hurt you're gonna have
to control your eating because when
people say when guys get hurt adam when
they come back
you're trying to get in shape right
and if you're putting all that stress on
your knees and your feet you're just
gonna keep getting hurt somebody has got
to be a grown person down in that
relationship and says yo man
you got to get in shape and i know he
got a lot of power
so
everybody's about probably like if we
don't get something going he's going to
leave but you're not going to win if
he's always hurt either no question
cause you don't play basketball to get
in shape you get in shape to play
basketball totally different and
you know
that is not you know he's a great
skilled player
but that is not basketball shape and
they're talking about he's two three
weeks that's not two three weeks away i
don't know when that footage i don't
know if it's tonight i think it was on
or saturday night that's not a two weeks
away
ready body for the nba uh that's not the
guy that we seen flying through the air
with the greatest of ease either and so
you know he
he does have to somebody say somebody
somebody down in new orleans got to be a
grown person
like moses moses my grown person
somebody gotta say yo man you got to get
in shape we can't win without maybe it's
valencianas
that's not two three weeks away